Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a Chinese comedy fantasy film
called “Ri Chang Huan Xiang Zhi Nan.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The protagonist of the movie is a con artist named
A Zhen. At the beginning of the movie, he steals a
historic statue from a well-secured museum. The
statue has several superstitions attached to it
as people believe that whoever has owned it in
the past has gone crazy in one way or the other.
After successfully getting his hands on the said
valuable, Zhen goes to meet his business partner,
brother Hei. He sells him other prehistoric
things that he has collected in the museum but
keeps the statue to himself. Brother Hei’s client
Adam is furious that he didn’t get the statue.
Later at night, Zhen is trying to start his car
when he notices that a car on the other side
of the road is slipping downhill. As he tries to
stop it, lightning strikes him and knocks him out.
A flashback of his childhood shows us that when
he was little, his principal had punished him for
stealing money from his wallet although it was a
prank set by his friends. Zhen was humiliated in
front of the entire school. That day, in a fit of
rage, he had asked God to hit him with lightning
if he had stolen the money. Back in the present,
he wakes up in his bed. To his surprise, the veins
on his arms have turned red and prominent.
Zhen doesn’t think much of it and opens the
fridge. At first glance, he sees someone’s face
inside it but when he looks again, it is gone.
Similarly, after his pees, the toilet turns
into a human and starts talking. Zhen is
beyond surprised. He walks out of the washroom
but hears his couch talking. Even his cat asks
him to get him a female cat. Soon, all the
objects in his room, including his TV, plants,
decorations, start to talk. Zhen quickly packs
up the valuable statue and runs outside. He sees
a man peeing in his car and scolds him but the man
turns out to be a stray dog. Zen starts to believe
that the lightning struck to his head has made
him go insane. He hurriedly gets into his car and
drives away in a rush. Some seconds later, his
car turns into an old man who asks him to drive
slowly. He sits beside Zhen in the front seat,
smiling at him. Zhen stops the car and runs to a
beach holding the bag that has the statue in it.
When he opens the bag, the statue talks to him.
The human form of the statue comes to life and
calls Zhen out for stealing him. Following that,
Zhen goes to the doctor to get his head
checked. The doctor happens to be the principal
who once accused him of stealing his money. When
the doctor refuses to believe that Zhen can talk
to things and animals, his computer turns into
a human and talks to Zhen. Using the computer,
Zhen tells the doctor about all the promiscuous
movies that are saved on his computer.
The doctor is left stunned. Now that the guy knows
that he is a pervert, the doctor suggests that
he go to a psychiatrist. As Zhen is leaving the
doctor’s office, he bumps into his childhood crush
and friend, Wang Caomei. She recognizes him
instantly and the two chat for a short time.
Zheng asks her about any disease that
may cause people to talk to objects.
Caomei only laughs at him and gives him her
card. After the brief encounter, Zhen’s mood
has gotten exponentially better. He asks his car
to talk to him but it refuses. Some minutes later,
it stops in the middle of the road. When Zhen
gets out to check, the engine explodes sending
him flying to the ground. Somehow, the statue has
landed safely on the road. The human form appears
and tells Zhen that he should practice good virtue
and return all the things he has stolen. Only,
then the objects will stop talking to him.
A while later, the repairmen are called and
the car is taken to the garage. Zheng wants it to
be repaired but the mechanic says that replacing
parts to such an old vehicle is not possible so
he should demolish it. After it is taken away,
Zhen notices a red mask on the road.
The mask talks to him and informs him of four
robbers who are on their way to rob a jewelry
shop. The scene shifts to a van where the said
robbers are driving to the said jewelry shop.
One of them has lost his mask so they kidnap a
woman and use her tights as a mask. However, when
they reach the shop, the police are already there
waiting for them. A few hours ago, Zhen was at
the police station to inform the police about
the robbers that the mask had told him about. The
police inspector thought he was a freak at first
but when Zhen communicated with his office table,
he believed him. After the robbers are caught,
the police officer asks Zhen to call his next of
kin, believing him to be a mentally ill person.
He calls Caomei to the police station who makes
the police officer understand that Zhen is not
in his right mind. They then go to the beach where
Zhen tells her everything that has happened to him
until then. Caomei refuses to believe him
and predicts that he is suffering from
Schizophrenia. She says that she is ready to
help him get back to his normal mental state.
Zhen agrees to act like he is mentally ill hoping
it will give him a chance to get closer to Caomei.
When she leaves, a lightning bolt strikes the
park bench he was sitting on seconds ago. The
bench’s human form chases Zhen, accusing
him of being the reason he was struck.
At night, Zhen goes to put the statue back in the
museum hoping that it will make him go back to
normal. The human form of the statue tells him
that since he is doing this for his own good,
it won’t help him. Still, Zhen keeps the statue
in the museum and leaves. The next day brother
Hei finds out that the statue was returned
by the thief. He is being pressured by his
associates to get a hold of the statue as soon
as possible because he has already accepted half
of the money. Meanwhile, Caomei holds a meeting
with all the doctors of the hospital, including
the former principal, to discuss Zhen’s condition.
The doctors, however, dismiss her concern,
saying that Zhen is faking his illness to get
closer to her. Except for the former principal,
who supports her view and allows her to help
him. At night, Zhen goes to an old temple to
return a book he had stolen. He sees a group of
monks training but they happen to be statues.
The chief monk takes the book from him and
praises Zhen for doing the right thing.
The following day, Caomei brings him
to a field when it is about to rain.
She makes him wear an antenna so the lightning
bolt would strike him again and cure his illness.
However, the plan doesn’t work because Zhen is too
scared to be struck. On their way back home, Zhen
thanks Caomei for being nice to him when they were
younger. It turns out that she was the only one
who believed him when the principal accused him
of stealing the money. They talk about a yellow
umbrella that Caomei used to carry everywhere. She
claims that it was her late mother’s only memory
but someone stole it a few years ago. She curses
the person who stole it not knowing that it was
actually Zhen. When he reaches home, he tries to
talk to the umbrella to apologize but it refuses
to talk to him. Following that, he brings out
a painting from his stash of stolen stuff.
The painting happens to be the Mona Lisa. To check
the authenticity of it, he brings it to a museum
and shows it to artist Adam. Adam is brother Hei’s
customer who has been pressuring him to steal the
statue. He disguises his illegal business
using the art gallery. To Zhen’s surprise,
Caomei is also at the art gallery. He finds out
that she is dating Adam and leaves right after.
The next day, Zhen is in the hospital with Caomei.
She has brought a lie-detecting machine wanting to
check if he is really telling her the truth. As
they talk, she asks him if he had a crush on her
when they were in school. Before Zhen can answer,
someone interrupts them. A few hours later,
Zhen goes to meet Adam again and finds him
painting a nude picture of a girl. It is clear
to him that Adam is cheating on Caomei. Zhen
cannot sleep that night. He contemplates if he
should tell Caomei the truth but his house plant
advises him against ruining her relationship.
Later that day, Caomei takes Zhen on a hot
air balloon ride to help him with his supposed
fear of heights. She has also brought him a
cake, remembering that it is his birthday.
Zhen is overwhelmed by the gesture. However, his
happiness doesn’t last long as on their way back,
he hears her talk to Adam on the phone.
Following that, Zhen goes to talk to Adam
about the original Mona Lisa painting he
owns but Adam refuses to believe him.
When he isn’t looking, Zhen takes the opportunity
to text all his flings on his phone. The next day,
all the girls, including Caomei, gather and
beat Adam up for playing them. Later that day,
she goes to a club with Zhen to get her mind off
her ex-boyfriend. They dance and drink the entire
night. Zhen brings her to his house because she
is too drunk to drive home. He quickly hides the
umbrella so she wouldn’t see it and they spend the
rest of the night watching TV. In the meantime,
a jealous Adam goes to brother Hei and shows him
CCTV camera footage of Zhen talking to his phone
and asking for the passcode. Adam has been keeping
an eye on him for the past few days and has found
out about his special power. However, brother
Hei doesn’t believe him. Back at Zhen’s home, his
belongings start to urge him to tell Caomei about
the umbrella. He gets annoyed by them and goes to
the dumping site to meet his old car. It is being
demolished so he wants to say the last goodbye.
The man version of the car tells him that it
used to deliberately break down when Zhen went
on a heist because it is the only way the car
could have stopped him from doing bad things.
Zhen apologizes for being rude to
him for all those years. They share
an emotional goodbye as the man disappears
into thin air and the car is demolished.
Following the encounter, Zhen goes to meet
Caomei and tells her about his powers.
He also hands her the yellow umbrella and
apologies for taking it. Caomei asks him to talk
to the umbrella and tell her what her mother's
last words were. The umbrella refuses to talk,
so Caomei doesn’t believe him. She storms off,
furious at his lies. After returning home that
day, Zhen looks at his arm and sees that the last
line of the vein that was red has turned normal,
meaning that all his debts are paid and he can
no longer talk to things. He gets a call from
brother Hei threatening him with Caomei’s
life and asking him to come to a warehouse.
Zhen rushes there to find out that Hei wants
him to talk to a locker that contains valuable
weapons and find out its passcode. If Zhen fails
to do so, he threatens to kill Caomei. She is hung
from a height on the other side of the room. Zhen
tries to communicate with the locker but cannot.
He tells them that he has lost his ability. Hei
is about to shoot him dead but the police arrive
at the right time and save both of them. When
Zhen returns home, he looks at his belongings
and reminisces about their constant chattering.
The movie ends as we see Caomei using her yellow
umbrella to protect Zhen from the rain.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.